Hey, welcome back. So, we're working on
a 2010 Honda Fit. It's a threeb button
key. Uh, let's go ahead and make a new
key. Uh, original key is toast went
through the washing machine. We're going
to make a new key. We got to program it
first. Let's get started. So, we have
our smart pro and we're going to go
ahead and turn the vehicle on. Dash
lights up and hit connect.
Voltage is pretty good.
On.
Great. Program keys two
and we switch off.
Switch on with the same key
and off again. Switch on with the next
key. Take that out. Put in the new key.
On
and off. And you guessed it, on.
Waiting for the immobilizer light to go
out. The little green light right there.
And the little key. You see that on all
the Hondas.
Let it kind of do its thing.
And off
and on.
Mobilizer light is out. Yes. Good. And
switch off.
Switch on.
Complete. Let's go ahead and crank it
on. Cool. Voltage is up. Ignition's on.
Let's check. Oh, it program all
together. Sometimes you'll see it where
programmed separately. And let's be
thorough, original key still has dead
battery or dead circuit board, but that
chip is still working. A-OK. Okay,
[Music]
cool. Other than that, have a great day
and I will see you next time. Stay fit
out there.